IMG to kick off to Bishop Sycamore
do you want my hands like this like this
like that just be natural you don't have
to try coach Roy Johnson told us they
had a number of division one prospects
oh hi Tim intercepted thanks in a pick
six and to the end zone Bill Waltz in
that will do it
do I look like a con artist
how this happens God a lot of people
scratching their head Bishop Sycamore is
not even real high school
they did not have teachers he really was
pretty much on our own
we didn't have any trainers people were
sharing helmets it was disgusting I was
literally sick to my stomach I can't
believe this happened again
my philosophy of business is do what the
people who have the money do even if you
don't have the money Roy will tell you
he's a liar he knew what to say how to
say it he's like oh man you gotta let
that go so I'm gonna tell you where I'm
gonna let go I'm gonna let go of his net
after I grab it I think I'm the most
honest liar that I know
how can you coach kids and you know it's
not a school boy would tell people
you're going to be playing in Alabama he
was just telling me a Dream well IO was
embarrassed by this they called the
thing explicitly a scam and then said
they couldn't do a damn thing about it
Bishop Sycamore does not happen if there
wasn't an abundance of money in high
school sports let's go did I break a law
is it illegal
am I in jail
we're on ESPN win lose a draw we win
this is not what we were supposed to
create how do I tell my mama that coach
wants me to do the same stuff that you
try to get me away from you say you care
about it but did you really
can we take a break that's some
[Applause]